morning
is boris johnson off the hook
after
126 fines that question is down to top
official sue gray whose report into
pandemic rule breaking in whitehall is
due out next week the prime minister
tried to leave partygate behind today to
go to tory welsh conference but
overnight he and others who work here
have been receiving letters telling them
what the grey report will say about them
should heads roll now over partygate
prime minister
are you worried about the sugree report
prime minister
are you worried about what's coming next
week prime minister or you just going to
pretend it never happened
one after another stories of parties and
gatherings have hung over boris johnson
for almost half a year he's hoping to
save the prospect that after the report
and one more address to parliament it
could all go away
that would be entirely up to
sue gray and
we'll be i'll be
looking forward very much to seeing what
she has to say
and
fingers crossed that will be that will
be pretty soon next week
prime minister wherever you are
ah he's here ladies and gentlemen
boris johnson keen to talk about
anything else with activists
just as we got the most difficult
challenges uh of kovid writing got the
big calls right we will get this country
through the big uh change of the big
challenges now and the post-covered
aftershocks we want to take wells
forward and we will take
we want to take britain forward together
using our strong economy to help the
whole country through the covered
aftershocks and taking the big decisions
now that will deliver a prosperous and
dynamic uk in the decades to come
decades in power that was the promise of
a booster-ish boris johnson here in
wales but behind the scenes that wasn't
quite the atmosphere that you see
yes they look like they'll continue to
keep him as prime minister nobody wants
to unseat boris johnson despite
partygate but they are weary of
defending him for tories at this
conference they're not sure the future
is bright
overall i would say it's not his best
speech and
it wasn't good reception
is he the right tory
leader
i'd like to see a bit more more of
another policy from a conservative
government we did come across a few
people who said they're not going to
vote for us just because of paris
however
there are many people who didn't care
about what's going on with the fines and
all that one senior tour suggested the
fines were fair game for the opposition
but i don't think one should ever sweep
aside an issue that
causes much negativity for the party
really as um as that issue if the
behavior that we just talked about had
been a labor politician you would have
been hammering them rotten wouldn't you
we probably would
pressure now building back in whitehall
the head of the civil service has pulled
out of a commons hearing next week could
simon case get the blame for the culture
that led to the fines despite not
getting one himself
partygate could have an unpredictable
end
sam coates sky news new town in wales